ein blick über die lehrer hafenpromenade
von rubin die stadt an der kroatischen
küste zählt zu den malerischsten
urlaubsorten an der adria doch von busen
den touristenmassen ist keine spur vom
diesmal wie seit montag haben wir hier
wieder angefangen restaurants und bars
zu öffnen
wir könnten auch hotels öffnen aber sie
sehen ja es gibt hier keine touristen
wir warten also ab wann die
landesregierung eine entscheidung fällt
über europäische touristen und dann
werden wir alles öffnen was möglich ist
trotz lockerung der korona maßnahmen
befindet sich roubini quasi noch im
winterschlaf
tourismus ist hier eine der
haupteinnahmequellen solange die gäste
ausbleiben wird vorbereitet was geht
genaugenommen führen wir hier sogar mehr
maßnahmen durch als von der regierung
gefordert jeder gast der hier eincheckt
wird ein fragebogen ausfüllen müssen
hatten sie kontakt zu infizierten sowas
wir werden nur eine zimmerbelegung von
50 prozent zu lassen die pool liegen
stehen alle in einem abstand von zwei
metern
gleiches gilt für die stühle im
restaurant alles zwei meter oder sogar
zwei hinein
gerade mal etwas über 2.200 corona
infizierte gab es bisher in kroatien ein
zeichen für die gute arbeit und
schnellen maßnahmen der regierung meinen
die menschen hier
was fehlt sind urlaubsgäste vor allem
die deutschen die jährlich den großteil
der touristen ausmachen
im moment ist das hier fast wie ein
corona freies land besonders die region
um istrien
ich hoffe die deutschen touris kommen so
schnell wie möglich wir vermissen die
deutschen wir mögen sie sehr
allerdings wird es noch etwas dauern bis
hier wieder deutsche urlauber flanieren
so lange heißt es für die einwohner von
roubini sprichwörtlich abwarten und tee
trinken bzw
kaffee endlich können wir also auf der
terrasse sitzen
die sonne genießen denn kaffee genießen
so langsam kommt das leben wieder zurück
wie es für die er war ja mein kollege
matthias katnik ist jetzt für uns in
court sind wir haben gerade die bilder
gesehen eigentlich ist kroatien ein
urlaubsziel der deutschen ein gern
gewähltes wie ist die situation aktuell
vor ort restaurants und einige wenige
und auch aktuell überhaupt urlaub machen
in kroatien das thema regierung streitet
man kann ist das nicht möglich
also aktion ist es so wenn man mit hotel
bestätigung an der grenze gibt das ist
keine hundertprozentige garantie ist
dass man reinkommt ich habe mir von
einer quelle sagen lassen sagt
bestätigen und das wird in den nächsten
tagen darüber nach was mit diskutiert
werden wichtig ist für abgebrochen
in deutschland niemand eben auch wieder
zurückkommt ohne in cremlingen zudem
kroatien gegen das corona virus wir
haben schon angefangen am 11 früher als
deutschland
und das waren so dass die bewohner ein
verlassen des einbrechers auf den halten
und man durfte dann den ort nur
verlassen wenn man zum beispiel zu
arbeiten oder ganz anderen gründen hatte
und insgesamt